- [Voiceover] So what I
wanna do in this video
is give ourselves an overview
of cellular respiration.
It can be a pretty involved
process, and even the way
I'm gonna do it, as messy as it looks,
is going to be cleaner
than actually what goes
on inside of your cells,
and other organs themselves,
because I'm going to show clearly from
going from glucose,
and then see how we can
produce ATP through glycolysis,
and the Krebs cycle,
and oxidative phosphorylation,
but in reality, all sorts
of molecules can jump in
at different parts of the
chain, and then jump out
at different parts of the chain,
to go along other pathways.
But I'll show, kind of
the traditional narrative.
So we're gonna start
off, for this narrative,
we're gonna start off with glucose.
We have a six-carbon-chain
right over here.
And we have the process of
glycosis, which is occurring
in the cytosol, the cytosol of our cells.
So if this is a cell right over here,
you can imagine, well the glycolysis,
the glycolysis could be
occurring right over there.
And that process of glycolysis
is essentially splitting up
this six-carbon glucose molecule
into two three-carbon molecules,
and these three-carbon molecules,
we go into detail in another
video, we call these pyruvate.
Pyruvate.
And in the process of
doing so, and this is,
I guess you could say,
the point of glycolysis,
we're able to, on a net
basis, produce two ATP's.
We actually produce four,
but we have to use two,
so on a net basis, we produce two ATP's.
I'm gonna keep a little
table here, to keep track.
So we produce two ATP's, and we are also,
we're also, in the process of that,
we reduce two NAD molecules to NADH.
Remember, reduction is
gaining of electrons.
And you see over here,
this is positively charged,
this is neutrally charged, it
essentially gains a hydride.
So this is reduction.
Reduction.
And if we go all the
way through the pathway,
all the way to oxidative phosphorylation,
the electronic transport chain,
these NADH's, the reduced
form of NAD, they can be, then, oxidized,
and in doing so, more energy
is provided to produce
even more ATP's, but we'll get to that.
So you're also gonna get two NADH's.
Two NADH's get produced.
Now at that point, you
could kind of think of it
as a little bit of a decision point.
If there's no oxygen around, or if
you're the type of organism that doesn't
want to continue, for some reason,
with cellular respiration,
or doesn't know how,
this pyruvate can be
used for fermentation.
We have videos on fermentation,
lactic acid fermentation,
alcohol fermentation,
and fermentation is all
about using the pyruvates
to oxidize your NADH back into NAD,
so it could be re-used
again, for glycolysis.
So even though the NADH has energy
that could eventually
be converted into ATP,
and even though pyruvates have energy
that could eventually
be converted into ATP,
when you do fermentation,
you kinda give up on that,
and you just view them as waste products,
and you use the pyruvate to
convert the NADH back into NAD,
And then, glycolysis can occur again.
But let's assume we're not gonna go down
the fermentation pathway, and we're
gonna continue with traditional
aerobic cellular
respiration, using oxygen.
Well, the next thing
that's going to happen,
is that the carboxyl group, and
and everything I'm going to show now,
it's going to happen for
each of these pyruvates.
So, you can imagine these
things all happening twice.
So I'm gonna multiply a
bunch of things, times two.
But what happens in the next step,
is this carboxyl group, this
carboxyl group is stripped
off of the pyruvate, and it, essentially,
is going to be released as carbon dioxide.
So this is our carbon
dioxide being released here,
and then the rest of our
pyruvate, which is, essentially,
an acetyl group, that
latches onto coenzyme A.
And you'll hear a lot about coenzyme A.
Sometimes I'll write just CoA, like this.
Sometimes I'll do CoA, and then
the sulfur, bonded to the hyrdrogen.
And the reason why they'll
draw the sulfur part,
is because the sulfur is what bonds
with the acetyl group, right over here.
So, you have the carbon
dioxide being released, and
then the acetyl group,
bonding with that sulfur,
and by doing that, you form acetyl-CoA.
And acetyl-CoA, just so
you know, you only see
three letters here, but this is
actually a fairly involved molecule.
This is actually a picture of acetyl-CoA,
I know it's really small, but hopefully
you'll appreciate that it's
a more involved molecule.
That, the acetyl group
that we're talking about
is just this part, right over
here, and it's a coenzyme.
It's really acting to
transfer that acetyl group,
and we'll see that in a second.
But it's also fun to
look at these molecules,
because once again, we see these patterns
over and over again in
biology or biochemistry.
Acetyl-CoA, you have an
adenine right over here.
It's hard to see, but you have a ribose,
and you also have two phosphate groups.
So this end of the
acetyl-CoA is essentially,
is essentially an ADP.
But it's used as a coenzyme.
Everything that I'm talking about,
this is all going to be facilitated
by enzymes, and the enzymes will have
cofactors, coenzymes, if
we're talking about organic
cofactors, that are gonna
help facilitate things along.
And as we see, the acetyl group joins on
to the coenzyme A, forming acetyl-CoA,
but that's just a temporary attachment.
The acetyl-CoA is,
essentially, gonna transfer
the acetyl group over to,
and now we're going to
enter into the citric acid cycle.
It's gonna transfer these two carbons
over to oxaloacetic acid,
to form citric acid.
So it's gonna transfer these two carbons
to this one, two, three,
four carbon molecule,
to form a one, two, three,
four, five, six carbon molecule.
But before we go into the depths
of the citric acid cycle,
I wanna make sure that
I don't lose track of my accounting,
because, even that step right over here,
where we decarboxylated the pyruvate,
we went from pyruvate to acetyl-CoA,
that also reduced some NAD to NADH.
Now, this is gonna happen
once for each pyruvate,
but we're gonna-
all the accounting we're gonna
say, is for one glucose molecule.
So for one glucose molecule, it's
gonna happen for each of the pyruvates.
So this is going to be times-
This is going to be times two.
So we're gonna produce two,
two NADH's in this step, going
from pyruvate to acetyl-CoA.
Now, the bulk of, I guess you could say,
the catabolism, of the
carbons, or the things that
are eventually going to produce our ATP's,
are going to happen in what we call
the citric acid, or the Kreb cycle.
It's called the citric
acid cycle because, when we
transferred the acetyl
group from the coenzyme A
to the oxaloacetic acid,
we formed citric acid.
And citric acid, this is the thing
that you have in lemons, or orange juice.
It is this molecule right over here.
And the citric acid cycle, it's
also called the Kreb cycle,
when you first learn it,
seems very, very complex,
and some could argue
that it is quite complex.
But I'm just gonna give you an
overview of what's going on.
The citric acid, once again, six-carboned,
it keeps getting broken
down, through multiple steps,
and I'm really not showing
all of the detail here,
all the way back to oxaloacetic acid,
where, then, it can accept
the two carbons again.
And just to be clear, once the two carbons
are released by the coenzyme A,
then that coenzyme A can be used
again, to decarboxylate some pyruvates.
So there's a bunch of cycles going on.
But the important take-away,
is as we go through the citric
acid cycle, as we go from
one intermediary to the next,
we keep reducing NAD to NADH,
in fact, we do this three
times for each cycle
of the citric acid cycle, but remember,
we're gonna do this for each acetyl-CoA.
For each pyruvate.
So all of this stuff is
going to happen twice.
So we're going to go through it twice
for each original glucose molecule.
So, here we have one, two,
three NADH's being produced,
but since we're going
to go through it twice,
and we're gonna be accounting for
the original glucose
molecule, we could say
that we have six
six NADH's,
or you could say, six
NAD's get reduced to NADH.
Now, you also, in the process,
as you're breaking down, going from
the six-carbon molecule
to four-carbon molecule,
you're releasing carbon,
as carbon dioxide,
and you also have, traditionally
GDP being converted
into GTP, or sometimes
ADP converted into ATP,
but functionally, it's
equivalent to ATP, either way.
So, we could also say
that we're gonna directly-
Remember, we're gonna do
all of this stuff twice.
So, we could say that two,
I'll just say two ATP's,
to make it simple.
We could say GTP, but I'll say two ATP's.
Because once again, this
happens once in each cycle,
but we're gonna do two
cycles, for each glucose.
And then, we have this other
coenzyme right over here,
FAD, that gets reduced to FADH2,
but that stays covalently
attached to the enzymes
that are facilitating it, so eventually,
that's being used to reduce .
coenzyme Q to QH2.
So I'm just gonna write the QH2 here, but
once again, you're gonna get two of these.
So two QH2's.
Now let's think about what the
net product, over here, is going to be.
And to think about it, we
should just, we'll just-
I'll do a little bit of a shorthand.
We'll go into more
detail in future videos.
These coenzymes, the NADH,
the QH2, these are going to be oxidized,
during oxidative phosphorylation,
and the electron transport chain,
to create a proton gradient across
the inner membrane of mitochondria.
We're gonna go into much
more detail in the future,
but that proton gradient is going
to be used to produce more ATP.
And one way to think about it, is
each NADH is going to produce,
and I've seen accounts, it
depends on the efficiency,
and where the NADH is actually going
to be produced, but it's going to produce
anywhere between two and three ATP's.
Each of the reduced coenzyme Q's,
so QH2,
that's going to each produce
about one and a half ATP's.
And people are still getting a good handle
on exactly how this is happening.
It depends on the efficiency of the cell,
and what the cell is
actually trying to do.
So, using these ranges, actually I'll say
one and a half to two ATP's.
And these are approximate numbers.
So let's think about what
our total accounting is.
So if we just count up
the ATP or the GTP's,
we're gonna get two there, two there.
So we're gonna have four direct,
or very close to direct,
ATP's net, being created.
And then how many NADH's?
We have two, four, and then we add six.
We have ten NADH's.
Ten NADH's.
And then, we have two of the coenzyme Q's.
Two QH2's.
So that's gonna be four ATP's,
this is going to be between-
this is going to be
between 20 and 30 NADH's.
Sorry, 20 and 30 ATP's.
20 to 30 ATP's.
And then, this is going
to be three to four.
Three to four ATP's.
So if you add them all together,
if you add the low ends
of the range, you get,
let's see, 20 plus three, plus four.
That's 27 ATP's.
27 ATP's.
And the high end of the range, let's see.
You have four plus 30 plus four.
You have 38.
38 ATP's.
And 38 ATP's is currently
considered to become
the theoretical maximum,
but when we actually
observe things in cells, it looks like
it comes right at around 29 to 30 ATP's.
And once again, it depends what the cell's
trying to do, the type of cells,
and the type of efficiency.
But all of this is happening
through cellular respiration.
And just to get a better sense
of where all of this is occurring.
Where all of this is occuring,
we said glycolosis is
occurring in the cytosol.
The citric acid cycle,
this is occurring in
the matrix of the mytochondria.
So this space right over here,
that is the citric acid cycle,
in that little magenta
space that I've drawn.
So that's the matrix.
In the video on mitochondria, we go
into much more detail on that.
And then, the actual conversion of
the coenzymes, of the
electron transport chain,
that's occurring across
the membrane of the crista.
And the crista are these
folds, these kind of,
inner membrane folds, of our mitochondria.
So, it's occurring across the membranes
of those, actually the plural is cristae.
Crista is the singular of the cristae.
And we'll go into more detail
into that, in other videos.